und nicht immer den prinzipien
entsprechen die im statut der uno
verankert sind wir sehen ich habe heute
ausführlich darüber gesprochen unseren
kollegen und freund antonio ätherisch
das in bedeutenden
hinsicht diese situation sich praktisch
sammelte und im wichtigsten kontexte
geschah das auch im ergebnis der von
unseren amerikanischen kollegen und
deren
verbündeten den kurs auf die grenzenlose
erweiterung der nato
verankerung der 1 polaren welt was
unsere geopolitischen raumes wurde das
alles getan und die russische föderation
einzudämmen und eben zu diesem zwecke
konsequent all dieser lange jahre die
ukraine benutzt wurde als der platz als
der brückenkopf für die reizen und für
eindämmung unseres landes es wurde die
aktivität der ukrainischen führung
unterstützt
verankerung der gesetze die russische
sprache russische kultur und alles
russischer im grunde verbieten und
parallel dazu
gesetzmäßig wurden die schritte
verankert die
nach vorne brachten immer noch nach die
nazistische theorie und narzisstische
praxis und natürlich der generalsekretär
ist bestens informiert über die
entscheidungen die auch erklärt wurden
vom präsidenten putin über gründe über
ziele der operation sie unsere militärs
gemeinsam mit den kämpfern
lugansk im territorium der ukraine
durchführung dieses ziele liegen in
erster linie im schutz der friedlichen
bevölkerung ist hier haben wir interesse
an der zusammenarbeit mit den kollegen
von der uhr genauso wie auch mit den
kollegen von der international ein
ausschuss des roten kreuzes was diese
zusätzliche mühen angeht zur
erleichterung des schicksals und
erleiden der zivilisten nach dem kontakt
stattgefunden haben inzwischen dem
generalsekretär der uno und unseren
verteidigungsministerium das geschah
bereits vor zwei monaten waren wir
einverstanden und haben eine
arbeitsgruppe gebildet die sich in
moskau befindet auf der grundlage
unseres
verteidigungsministeriums die vertreter
der uno vereinbaren konkrete dinge die
helfen ohne gefahr die humanitäre hilfe
zu bringen und mit den kräften der uno
die verwaltung der ohne für humanitäre
fragen gelang es bereits solche fünf
humanitärer konvois in verschiedene
bereiche der ukraine zu entsenden zum
ergänzung der humanitären hilfe die ihr
mal wieder an die ukrainischen bürger
und auch anton s und so ganz
seitens der russischen
verteidigungsministeriums und des
ministeriums für ausnahmezustand auf
eine reihe von auch zivilen organisation
wir haben heute auch die möglichen
aktionen besprochen bei der festigung
dieser zusammenarbeit ich glaube in
folge der verhandlungen in moskau können
wir bestimmen dass solche schritte die
wahl ziehen abgefragt werden können
durch in der jetzigen situation und
zweifellos sprachen wir über die
schicksale der uno insgesamt über die
versuche in erster linie unser
westlichen kollegen die schlüsselfragen
die besprechung außerhalb der
offiziellen formate unter der unteren
system heraus zu tragen verschiedene
aufrufe zu machen verschiedene
partnerschaften zu schmieden die
präsentiert werden als der flug der
ausgewählten der fortgeschrittene in
diesem strom verlaufen auch die
initiative die von frankreich und
deutschland auch aufgestellt wird ein
allianz der multilateralismus das ist
doch eine konkurrenz zu ohne wurde die
initiative der vereinigten staaten die
im letzten jahr denn gefällt der
demokratie ausgerufen haben und dabei
haben sie selbstständig ausgerufen haben
mit keinem haben sie sich überraschen
und das ist auch und wir haben unsere
gesprächspartner darauf hingewiesen dass
das auch ein gefährliches klingelzeichen
für die uno ist der versuch die
grundlegenden regeln des staates zu
überstreichen die grundsätze der uni
wegzustreichen eben weil die
organisation auf der grundlage der
souveränen freiheit der staaten
gegründet wurde das steht im statut und
das muss man in ihren und rufen wir
werden das häufige machen damit keiner
in weder in new york noch in den
hauptstädten der mitgliedstaaten daran
vergessen ich möchte zum ende kommen mit
dem ausdruck der äußersten dankes dem
generalsekretär der mit initiative
aufgetreten ist einen solchen kontakt zu
machen und wir meldeten uns sofort das
betont die große bedeutung die wir dem
regelmäßigen dialog und im vergleich der
position mit dem generalsekretär ist
toll ich glaube bei allen
schwierigkeiten die internationalen
fragen immer mehr werden solche offenen
diskussion ob es das nützlichste damit
wir letztendlich zu quellen kommen zum
statut der ohne und eben auf der
grundlage dieser stadt tut ist jegliche
der entwicklung der mozilla ried
entwickeln das ist die multi laterit ist
so zu einer der wichtigsten der - und
deswegen bin ich sehr sehr dankbar dass
er in diesem kontext unser gespräch
aufgebaut hat danke
dann bin ich nach moskau gereist und
dort meine ziele vorzutragen
meine agenda
es geht darum menschenleben zu retten
leiden zu vermindern wir haben offene
gespräche geführt mit
aushubmaterial aufruf unter anderem
verschiedene positionen dargelegt
dass die generalversammlung hat sich
schon dazu geäußert spricht von einer
verschwörung
viele tausende menschen sind getötet
wurden vier zivilisten und viele viele
sind auch eingeschlossen und vom tode
bedroht ich habe von wiederholten
verletzungen
der menschenrechte gesprochen und hier
ist eine unabhängige ermittlung nötig um
die schuld richtig zuweisen zu können
wir haben humanitäre korridore verlangt
die wirklich sicher und wirksam sein
wird und die auch von allen eingehalten
werden
um zivilisten zu retten und die dringend
benötigte hilfe dorthin kommen zu lassen
das habe ich vorgeschlagen eine
militärische kontaktgruppe für bilden
zwischen der russischen föderation der
ukraine und den vereinten nationen um
nach möglichkeiten zu suchen und sichere
korridore zu schaffen
die feindseligkeiten örtlich
einzustellen und um dafür zu sorgen dass
dies auch vor ort wird gleichzeitig
haben wir ein dass wir immer jubel von
einer echten krise stehen tausende von
zivilisten
brauchen dringend
lebensrettende hilfe und viele viele
müssen evakuiert werden die vereinten
nationen sind bereit ihre logistischen
und personellen ressourcen einzusetzen
um in mariupol menschenleben zu retten
ich schlage vor dass die vereinten
nationen hier zusammen mit den
interessierten roten kreuz der ukraine
und den vertretungen der russischen
föderation zusammenzuarbeiten um
zivilisten ist kreieren zu können
sowohl in der umgebung von adorf als
auch in anderen bereichen in die
gewünschte richtung die in die diese
menschen gebracht werden wollen und das
ist zurzeit nicht das was sich in der
ukraine zu tricks schockwellen laufen
und die welt angesichts der dortigen
ereignis die krise verschärft sich bei
lebensmitteln bei der energieversorgung
das war ja schon im letzten jahr ein
problem aber jetzt werden hunderte
von millionen von menschen auch weltweit
von der lebensmittelkrise betroffen
das kommt hin zu rock it 19 circa
pandemie
und erschwert die hilfe gerade die
entwicklungsländer rund um die welt sind
hier stark betroffen sie ihr also der
frieden wieder hergestellt wird desto
besser ist es für
die ukraine für russland und die ganze
welt
das ist nun wirklich sehr wichtig dass
gerade in diesen zeiten der
schwierigkeiten
die fährte des multilateralismus am
leben zu erhalten
wir brauchen eine multipolare welt
mit multilateralen institutionen die
multilaterale institutionen
müssen sich nach der karte der vereinten
nationen un nach dem völkerrecht richten
und die beachtung der un-charta und des
völkerrechts
bedeutet dass die völlige gleichheit der
staaten gewährleistet wird und dann ist
das hoffentlich ein instrument das uns
einmal mehr erheblich zusammenzufinden
als vertreter der menschheit um die
dramatischen herausforderungen
anzunehmen die nicht entgegenstehen
klimawandel und so weiter und so fort
und der einzige krieg den wir führen
dürfen muss ein krieg gegen das sein was
unseren planeten gefährdet
bedarf zu tun
deutlich fitter borgen ich habe eine
frage
und sie beide
der seefahrt nation fleisch erste hotel
es gibt ja hat behauptungen gegen
behauptungen zum thema genozid
völkermord kriegsverbrechen menschliche
schutzschilde es gibt berichte über bio
waffen und chemiewaffen sie haben von
einer kontaktgruppe und humanitären
korridor gesprochen und von ermittlungen
werden die vereinten nationen sich um
unabhängige ermittlungen kümmern und ein
team bilden ein ermittlungsteam dass
sich vor ort um sieht und die tatsachen
ermittelt dann eine frage an den
außenminister
beide seiten ob nun die uno oder die
völkergemeinschaft
wollt ja verhandlungslösung und einen
waffenstillstand haben wert russland
eine verhandlungslösung anstreben gibt
es an land oder eine organisation das
als mediator als vermittler auftreten
könnte wen würde russland dabei
bevorzugen oder vorschlagen danke
er hat der fight nation hat nicht die
möglichkeiten die ermittlungen selbst
anzustellen
es gibt den internationalen
strafgerichtshof es gibt die
verschiedenen mechanismen die schon
gebildet worden
im menschenrechts system da gibt es auch
ermittlungen instanzen ich habe nur
nicht die absicht selbst ermittlungen
einzuleiten dazu bin ich nicht befugt
aber ich halte es für sehr wichtig dass
wir unabhängige ermittler haben damit
vor der glaubwürdigkeit und voller
rechenschaftspflicht gegeben sind
jetzt
was die frage angeht ja nicht gestellt
wurde möchte ich sagen über die position
die die weltgemeinschaft einnimmt und
wie die uno sich mit von diesen
positionen leiten lassen soll natürlich
neben den unvermeidlichen
prinzipien der stadt taste und der
gleichheit der staaten der herr
generalsekretär verwies sich auf die
resolution der generalversammlung
in der russland verurteilt wurde und
wurde das was in der ukraine geschieht
als invasion bezeichnet als verletzung
der souveränität der integrität und ich
möchte sagen dass diese resolution kein
konsens hatte dass ihr wurde abgestimmt
und viele staaten haben sich bei uns
beschwert dass manche regelrecht
gezwungen hat dass die botschafter in
den fluren der ohne eingefangen wurden
und den angedroht worden die einen
hatten irgendwelche konten in einem
tasche band bei anderen studierten die
kinder ihren wo ich betreibe das nicht
sowas hat es gegeben und dennoch wurde
die resolution nicht einstimmig
verabschiedet
worden und einige dutzende von staaten
haben sich geweigert sie zu unterstützen
natürlich jede resolution der
generalversammlung soll als mandat für
sekretariat dienen aber auch die
resolution des sicherheitsrates für
sekretariat heilig sein sollen
insbesondere die resolution wenn sie im
konsens verabschiedet werden wenn alle
15 mitglieder für eine konkrete lösung
abgestimmt und ebene im konsens im
februar 2015 ein dokument verabschiedet
wurde und bestätigt das
minsk maßnahmen komplex hier geht er die
rede über die notwendigkeit eines
direkten dialogs zwischen kindern ist
und wo sonst alle dort entstandene
probleme im rahmen der totalen
integrität der ukraine zu regeln man
musste nur die verpflichtung erfüllen
unter denen zuerst mal die unterschrift
gestellt haben zuerst mal präsident
bashir und dann präsident will ins
gewicht und einen sonderstatus der
neuesten looks diesen erklärten
republiken erklären sie amnestie für
dich gewährleistet auch gewährleisten
die ergänzt die änderungen in die
verfassung der ukraine über die
dezentralisiert aber bei der
beibehaltung der territorialen
integrität ukraine und das sollte da
auch dort organisiert sollten auch die
wahlen organisiert werden unter
vereinbarung mit donetsk und so ganz ich
kann mich nicht erinnern dass der
generalsekretär der uno irgendwie
reagiert hat gegen die direkte grobe
sabotage diese dieser vereinbarungen
obwohl ja die resolution der
sicherheitsrates ein teil des
völkerrechtes sind wir haben darüber
heute gesprochen und ich wir kennen
einander seit lang wir haben unter
kameradschaftliche beziehungen ich bin
der meinung dass ein solches gespräch
unmöglich
wir befinden uns jetzt bei der
entwicklung der internationalen
beziehungen wo die stunde der wahrheit
kommt entweder sind wir alle damit
einverstanden dass jemand alleine mit
der gruppe der satelliten entscheidet
wie die menschheit leben soll oder die
menschheit wird leben auf der grundlage
der stadt so dass der unterricht so
simpel ist das alles keiner möchte
irgendwelchen kriege gott verhüte das
aber argumente vorzulegen antworte zu
verlangen von denen sie den staat tut
der ohne verletzte das muss unbedingt
geschehen und ich kann sie versichern
dass immer mehr staaten besonders die
staaten mit der eigenen geschichte
kultur zivilisation
eben diese position vertreten und wollen
denn irgendwann muss das geschehen ich
hoffe sehr dass ausgerechnet die wohnung
mit deren bossen in die impfstatus
sitzen das ist das grösste dokument
aller zeiten und völker eine solche
katalysieren rolle spielen wir bei
entwicklung eines solchen
ehrlichen wiederhole ich dialogs ohne
ultimatum ohne
drohungen ohne versuchen mit gewalt
probleme zu lösen einschließlich auch
mit der kraft und gewalt der finanzen
und der wirtschaft mit aldi den kräften
die unter westlichen kollegen haben und
dabei wären stellung im internationalen
system missbrauchen und zwar schon
schrankenlos ist meine meinung ist was
sie verhandlungs fragen angeht wir sind
für verhandlungen wie sie wissen wir
haben direkt nach anfang märz als
präsident allianz geht die verhandlungen
angeboten hat waren die einzigen arbeit
wie sich die ukrainische delegation
benommen hat bei dem verwarnungen und
wie der präsident sie lenski selbst sich
benommen hat er war nicht bereit die das
zu bestätigen was die vor einer woche
von uns bekommen hat das natürlich macht
uns traurig bedrückt uns wir so sieht
die verhandlungen interessiert und sie
nicht so sehr die stützen sich darauf
dass das diejenigen
versprochen haben die die dazu auf
gruppen man darf nicht zulassen dass
russland siebte beziehungsweise dir das
so auf rot russland zu besiegen und zu
zerstören
dass sie diese linie weiter fortführen
werden durch viele waffen die in die
ukraine geliefert werden in großen
mengen wenn das weiter fortgesetzt wird
dann werden die warnungen kaum
irgendwelche ergebnisse bringen aber ich
wiederhole wir sind hier verhandlungsweg
wir sind auch für die einstellung der
feuer damit beschäftigen wir uns jeden
tag in den wir romane thera korridore
verkünden sie
ignoriert werden zum beispiel durch die
sich hin als ob sie verschätzten kämpfer
von as of style die mit hakenkreuzen
herum spazieren mit den emblemen von
eses waffen-ss uns war die wenn als
präsidentiellen ski sagte wir haben
viele solche bataillons ist und ebenso
wie sie die sind so wie sie sind hat man
in seinem interview herausgeschnitten es
schien also doch sehr
hat man sich geschämt der westlichen
demokratischen gesellschaft dazu
präsentieren mit all seinen geheimen
gedanken deshalb wir sind bereit zu
verhandlungen will jemand irgendwelche
interessanten ideen hat sind wir bereit
den zuzuhören über die vermittlung jetzt
zumindestens bei der
vorausgehenden verhandlungen haben die
ukrainischen verhandlungspartner darüber
nicht gesprochen unsere mannschaft und
treffen sich zu
haben sich drei mal in belarus getroffen
einmal in der türkei haben sich
getroffen dass die plätze zur
verhandlung wir sind dankbar so wollten
eine es auch den anderen view die
gastfreundschaft für die organisation
der verhandlungen über die vermittler
jetzt zu sprechen glauben wir ist noch
zu früh wir möchten die antwort auf die
letzte fassung des
übergeben haben und die ukraine schon
verhandlungspartner haben dem
präsidenten darüber nicht berichtet
zumindestens er hat gesagt er
dazu nur folgendes sagen
gehört richtet sich nach allen
revolution der glatt versammlung des
sicherheitsrats und wenn ich heute etwas
bedauere dann ist es das die vereinten
nationen nicht die erlaubnis gehalten
erhalten haben am dom uniformer
teilzunehmen um das münchner abkommen im
auge zu behalten
und eine eindeutige meinung entstehen zu
lassen über das scheitern des minsker
abgrunds
zum anderen möchte ich noch sagen dass
durchaus verstehe dass die russen
generation mit vielen problemen zu
kämpfen hat die karte der vereinten
nationen sieht eine reihe von
nachrichten vor mit denen man problemen
begegnen kann
vor allem
unter hinzuziehung des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs oder gerichtshof wenn
die anderen mittel die in der charta
vorgesehen sind nicht ausreichend
etwas liegt außerdem auf der hand und
das lässt sich durch keine hinweise
ändern
es gibt keine ukrainischen truppen auf
dem staatsgebiet der russischen
föderation aber russische truppen auf
dem gebiet der ukraine
das bestätige ich
lerne rufen sie mir erlauben ich habe
fragen an beide sprecher
heute wird die abstimmung über die
resolution von lindt steine über
vetorecht und das setzt voraus dass e
mail wenn einer der starken der
sicherheitsrat das vetorecht ein weg wie
betrachtet moskau diese initiative und
wie steht überhaupt die russische seite
zur vorschlags zur reformierung des
sicherheitsrates und auch initiative zur
aufhebung des entsprechenden vetos nach
der
und herrisch die frage an sie wie sie
als generalsekretär der ohne halten sie
das für notwendig für notwendig das
recht veto recht zu reformieren
jetzt jetzt was die resolution an geht
das jetzt eingebracht wurde in die
generalversammlung diese resolution das
wurde ganz klar vereinbart hat kein
bezug und wird überhaupt nicht die
verhandlungen beeinflussen die seit
jahren geführt werden über die reform
des sicherheitsrates das vetorecht
bleibt sie nicht wird nirgendwo
verschwinden ich kann das bestätigen
das wird recht ist eine der tragenden
stützen der uno ohne ohne dieses rechts
wird der organisation zerfallen denn sie
großmächte sind die ständigen mitglieder
des sicherheitsrates natürlich stützen
sich auf den grundsatz der
einstimmigkeit
diese einstimmig fest verankert im stadt
und das vermeidet eine scharfe
konfrontation zwischen den zu vermeiden
andere sache dass die welt sich
verändert haben und die amerikaner
erklären jetzt
einstimmig dass sie von dieser welt zu
sein
polar machen möchten für immer aber die
welt ist multi buller und wir sagten
mehrfach dass der sicherheitsrat sein
schlimmstes defekt vermeiden mal eben
die über übergewicht von von einer art
von staaten von
66 viel zu viele
die unter die entwicklungsländer sind
unterrepräsentiert und wir haben
mehrfach gesagt wir wollen die daten von
asien und lateinamerika als mitglieder
dieses organs sein und wir haben auch
namentlich unser partner aus indien und
brasilien erwähnt aber dabei muss auch
eine ein vertreter
von afrika seien deshalb diese
resolution die sie erwähnt haben wird
dieses voraus dass bei der
generalversammlung die situation
besprochen wird was passiert nach dem
einsatz des vetorechts das hat kein
bezug das ist gerichtet auf die
demokratisierung bei der
entscheidung müsse beim entscheidungs
treffen und wir sind bereit uns dem
konsens anzuschließen wenn dieser
konzerns entstehen es ist wichtig auf
der grundlage des konsenses zu arbeiten
denn viele resolution die auch durch die
mehrheit der stimmen verabschiedet
werden auf einmal übergeben in den
richtungen die besonders für die
westlichen staaten von vorteil sind ich
würde noch weiter gehen sicherheitsrat
kann auch die möglichkeit genommen
werden eine resolution zu verabschieden
nicht nur durch den einsatz von einem
oder zwei wetter sondern auch durch
zurückhaltung bei der abstimmung von
sechs oder sieben starten das ist auch
der fall von in dem der sicherheitsrat
gespalten
sein wird und ich glaube die
generalversammlung darf nicht
gleichgültig gegenüber eine derartigen
situation stehen deshalb ich glaube dass
es dein person der prozess wenn ein land
das veto-recht
einsetzt das heißt sie sind in der lage
ihre abstimmung erklären und in den
fällen wenn es um die russische
föderation geht vielleicht gibt es auch
solche fälle wird während der lager
seien überzeugen die ein oder anderen
position zu erklären die wir beim
sicherheitsrat einnehmen
das deuten kann
vor so vielen jahren für carter gesagt
wurde so lag der grund für das veto
polare dass man eine situation vermeiden
porta in der eine konfrontation entsteht
zwischen den mitgliedern
mitgliedern der gruppe der ständigen
mitglieder in der befürchtung dies
könnte zu einem weltkrieg führen das
veto war also ein element mit dem man
eine derartige entwicklung vermeiden
wollte es ist auch richtig dass im laufe
der jahre das veto wahrscheinlich zu
häufig eingelegt wurde in vielen fällen
wurde auch ohne dass die vitale
interessen des landes berührt fahren wo
das also eingesetzt ohne berührung der
vitalen interessen eines landes das hat
es gegeben ich bin also sehr dafür dass
man das veto
moderate hat habt ich glaube nicht dass
man es einfach abschaffen kann das
fedpol keine mehrheit finden in der
versammlung
da dürften kaum die 52 mitglieder
zustimmen aber es ist sicherlich wichtig
den sicherheitsrat zu erweitern um eine
gerechtere vertretung zu gewährleisten
gerade staaten aus afrika
wird in doppelter hinsicht von kursen
calis muss betroffen einmal weil man
dort unter kolonialismus zu leiden hatte
und viele staaten sind ja erst
unabhängig geworden als die
internationalen institutionen bereits
bestanden afrika ist also im
entscheidungsprozess
unterrepräsentiert in vielen der
internationalen organisationen ich
glaube also dass wir eine stärkere
vertretung der entwicklungsländer in
vielen bereichen und den
bretton-woods-institutionen bis hin zum
sicherheitsrat ein wichtiger fortschritt
wäre
[Musik]
fragen richten sich an herrn minister
die als der frage wie hat russland auf
die
auf den vorschlag der ukrainischen seite
über den durchführung einer besonderen
verhandlungsrunde auf dem territorium
der stadt mainz weiter frage welche
maßnahmen werden von der russischen
seite getroffen in bezug auf die auf
zuwachs der waffen durch der amerikaner
ja ich habe
gehört über eine solche theatralisch
präsentierte einen vorschlag der
ukrainischen mannschaft diese mannschaft
die mit unseren verhandlungen
us-vertretern
kommuniziert hat in belarus und dann in
der türkei dass sie vorgeschlagen habe
die nächste sitzung der
in mario besser führen an den wänden von
azoff schnell in der tat das ist eine
theatralische gesten die ukraine
inszenieren gerne alles ist anscheinend
wollten sie noch irgendwelche
herzzerreißende szene produzieren wenn
es um die ernsthafte einstellung auf die
zusammenarbeit im rahmen der
verhandlungen dann sollen sie lieber
schneller unsere vorschläge beantworten
die bereits mehr als zehn tagen auf
deren seite liegen und von denen selbst
williams gemacht nichts gehört hat jetzt
über die lieferung der waffen an kilos
ist nicht nur amerikaner liefern waffen
die bevorzugen nach europa diese waffen
zu bringen obwohl sie die europa dazu zu
bewegen dass sie das macht obwohl sie
selbst auch solche schritte unternehmen
und wir sagten schon mehr von wenn die
ausländischen waffen auf dem in der
ukraine
das ist eine legitime ziel für unsere
militärische operation unserer truppen
stehen auf dem territorium der ukraine
unsere truppen verteidigen die rechte
der menschen sie seit 18 jahren rum
basiert wurden unabhängig ob das noch
mein sie format war da nicht all die
staaten schwiegen auch deutschland und
frankreich die mitverfasser der minsker
vereinbarungen all die jahre wurden
wurde die gesamte russischsprachige
bevölkerung nicht nur in den bass von
zwei republik unterzogen sondern die
ganze ukraine wurde unterdrückt schauen
sie mal das steht alles in der statistik
solche gesetze wurden verabschiedet in
bezug auf die russische sprache in der
suppe auf die massenmedien russischer
sprache
dabei wurden nicht nur die russischen
kanäle verboten es wurden auch die
ukrainischen kanäle verboten wenn sie
sich in den händen einer oppositionellen
partei im parlament saß betroffen es
wurde auch letztendlich über schlossen
eine russische sprache im alltag zu
verbieten es wurde die nazistische
ideologie und praxis
eingepflanzt alle haben schamhaft die
köpfe im sand versteckt sowohl im rahmen
von normandie format als auch außerhalb
von diesem format und sie warfen die
schon damals in die ukraine geliefert
wurden die stellten eine reale gefahr
dafür die russische föderation die
militärische stützpunkte die briten
gebaut haben am asowschen meer er war
aber haben direkt eine gefahr
dargestellt und leider haben wir keine
sympathisierenden stimmen gehört aus
verschiedenen ecken der welt wir bereits
als letzter versuch wir im herbst den
amerikanern und nato staaten
vorgeschlagen haben verträge
abzuschließen die darauf gerichtet war
die sicherheit in europa zu sichern ohne
dabei nicht die mitgliedschaft in den
militärisch politischen blogs zu
erweitern wir beschäftigen uns jetzt mit
der beseitigung dieser gefahren oder der
beseitigung der aktionen die der westen
unternommen hat in unter verletzung der
verpflichtungen die eigene sicherheit zu
stärken auf kosten der sicherheit
russlands und die letzte frage agentur
sputnik
einen schönen guten tag
ich habe die frage
spreche vor kurzem hatte russland den
ersten diplomaten von der regierung der
taliban akkreditiert bedeutet dass in
richtung auf die anerkennung der
regierung details
unsere zweite
russland einverstanden mit den
innerafghanischen politischen kräften
zusammen zu arbeiten gerecht weil es
immer sache der einbeziehung der
regierung wie das der iranische
vertreter ihr brechen tc fans wie können
sie die rechtliche ex profilierung der
hässliche ex-profi ehrung der russischen
gaz russischen diplomatischen eigentums
und auch missbraucht das
status
der empfangenen seite wenn man schon
diplomaten verweigert wird die
genehmigung bei der beteiligung an
manchen sitzungen der uno dazu nehmen
welche man
die zweite frage über afghanistan
sie haben jetzt die usa aufgerufen die
afghanischen aktiver
glocken um keinen kollaps der wirtschaft
ja in der tat wir haben akkreditiert
einen diplomaten
bereits nach moskau geschickt wurde von
der neuen machthaber die bewegung
taliban
das bedeutet nicht dass er das
keinesfalls die offizielle diplomatische
anerkennung
wir befinden uns in ihr sonne wir
handeln in unis ohne mit den wichtigsten
nachbarn von afghanistan in china fand
vor kurzem eine repräsentative konferenz
statt wir beteiligten uns da an dieser
konferenz mit vertretern der asiatischen
staaten und pakistan er an wir handeln
auf der grundlage der realität notstand
sind wir haben kontakte mit der liebe
über unser botschaften über vertreter
unserer ente die zugleich die fragen der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit
betrachten ich möchte darauf hinweisen
dass wären
sowjetunion in afghanistan war da
existierte über 140 unternehmen die zum
zum grundstein der wirtschaft und
während der präsenz der nato koalition
wurde kein einziges unternehmen gebaut
in afghanistan es reduziert sich alles
wissen sie worauf und wie das endete
deshalb wir wollen den dialog
führen und wir wollen also weiter die
vollständige diplomatische anerkennung
ihre verpflichtungen
erfüllen und eine inklusive regierung
schaffen und und zwar nicht nur nach
nach nach dem politisch inclusive sie
haben jetzt auch verschiedene
nationalitäten aber die sind alle da
leben die dieses politische inklusive
steht muss unsere weiteren schritten
richte man wir arbeiten mit politischen
kräften die sich in kabul in afghanistan
befindet da ist der frühere präsident
karzai auch andere führende personen die
interesse haben am dialog mit taliban
und bei unseren kontakten mit taliban
für dann wir sie damit dieser dialog in
gang kommt und dass dieser dialog weiter
fortgeführt wird
ich fange mal mit afghanistan an
wir haben schon von anfang an
beschlossen uns aktiv auf die taliban
einzustellen und wir haben auch
humanitäre maßnahme in afghanistan
eingeleitet aber das allein das habt ihr
erkannt reicht nicht aus wenn kein geld
da ich keine liquidität in darf gar
nicht schon wirklich vorhanden ist dann
ist der zusammenbruch der wirtschaft
etwas das wirklich verheerende folgen
für die bevölkerung in afghanistan haben
kann
wir haben also verlangt dass die
internationale gemeinschaft die
voraussetzung schaffen
ich muss
dafür das geld in die afghanische
wirtschaft
gesteckt werden kann mit dem flugzeug
sind banknoten in großen mengen 5
millionen dollar nach afghanistan
geflogen worden wir haben die weltbank
dazu gebracht dass man von dort aus
beträge freigibt die
dort in bezug auf afghanistan vorgesehen
sind und wir arbeiten auch mit der
zentralbank und dem
amerikanischen senat mit ihm zusammen um
die hindernisse zu beseitigen die es
noch gibt was die ludwig kite angeht
gelder freizugeben die ich noch immer
sind wir hoffen dass das für alle
staaten gilt die dort vermögenswerte
eingefroren haben
wir glauben natürlich dass wir alles tun
müssen für das wohl der afghanischen
bevölkerung
aber wir lassen uns auch erbschaft auf
die taliban ein um diese inklusive tät
der regierung sicherzustellen die
gleichstellung von männern und frauen
zum beispiel aber auch zwischen muss
bieten
sarah und anderen völkerschaften die an
den prozess in afghanistan teil den
müssen was die notwendigkeit angeht dass
afghanistan keine grundlage darstellen
die touristische aktivitäten außerhalb
des staatsgebiet und natürlich auch für
die bekämpfung des terrorismus in
afghanistan selbst dass das aus der
ambulanz für müssen natürlich auch die
grundrechte eingehalten werden da
beschäftigt mich vor allem zwei fragen
die möglichkeit das mädchen in die
schule gehen hören gerade auch in
weiterführende schulen und an
universitäten
kommen können hat derzeit einen
negativen bestürzte geben doch wirklich
mal
zur seite geschoben werden wird ad acta
gelegt werden wird damit frauen auch
dort arbeiten können wie sich das ja bei
den weiblichen mitarbeiter vereinten
nationen gezeigt hat die zurzeit sehr
viel zu tun haben
andererseits glaubt wir auch das sehr
wichtig dass da wirklich starten auch
die russische föderation
normal
mit den erfordernissen umgehend
gebrauchen die pforte beteiligung aller
staaten an den verfahren der vereinten
nationen und wir werden eine sehr starke
position
hierbei vertreten dafür sorge zu tragen
dass wir schnell in diese richtung
bewegen sind
wurde die zweite frage so machen wir die
diplomaten
wie weit die pressekonferenz von antonio
guterres generalsekretär der vereinten
nationen und sergey lavrov der
außenminister russlands frank umbach ist
noch im studio politikwissenschaftler
das weiß ganz schön viel stoff sehr viel
sage ich mal auch gewöhnungsbedürftige
rhetorik dabei von von herrn labors
lassen uns das gemeinsam einordnen es
gab das thema natürlich ukraine es ging
ein bisschen speziell nachher auch um
die vereinten nationen hinten raus um
afghanistan kokain ist natürlich das
thema was uns am dringendsten
beschäftigter gab es ja gewisse hoffnung
die verbunden war mit dem besuch hotels
in moskau aus ihrer sicht haben sich die
bestätigt die hoffnung nein leider nicht
also man durfte vielleicht auch nicht zu
optimistisch sein aber man hatte doch
vielleicht gehofft dass es gerade aus
mario pohl die möglichkeit eines
humanitären korridors gibt weil die
nahrungsmittelvorräte und alles vieles
andere geht nun einmal zu nah es gab
mehr versuche die zivilisten
herauszubringen das ist offensichtlich
aufgrund russischer blockaden immer
wieder gescheitert und wir kennen das so
ein bisschen aus der vergangenheit auch
im syrienkonflikt selbst da wo
humanitäre korridore eingerichtet worden
ist sondern diese korridor tatsächlich
dann sogar nachher beschossen worden
also insoweit muss dann wirklich
sicherheit gegeben sein deswegen kann
ich die ukrainische seite dann schon
verstehen die sagen solange diese
sicherheit nicht gegeben ist können wir
nicht sozusagen die zivilisten aus den
kellern holen und er hat sehr blumig
gesprochen und ist damit letztendlich
aber auch der frage ausgewichen ob es
irgendeinen fortschritt gibt und hat
eben erkennen lassen dass russland keine
kompromisse in diesen fragen offen sich
zulässt es gab eine position der
un-generalsekretär gesagt hat ja wir
werden eine kontaktgruppe einrichten
zwischen dem russischen außenministerium
und der un in bezug auf die humanitärer
flüchtlingsfragen aber eine solche
kontaktgruppe die sich dann auch vor ort
tatsächlich umschaut wie das ja
intendiert offensichtlich war von dem
generalsekretär setzt ja zunächst mal
einen waffenstillstand irgendwie voraus
ja ansonsten würde kein un gruppe da
hineingehen und hängt wieder dann von
dem goodwill russlands ab und da haben
wir in der vergangenheit gesehen dass es
immer mal wieder solche zusagen gab die
aber letztendlich dann politisch nicht
eingehalten und da wolf sprach in dem
zusammenhang auch von der stunde der
wahrheit und er hat vielleicht noch ganz
interessant vor dem gespräch mit antonio
guterres vor der realen gefahr eines
weltkrieges gewarnt und sozusagen in
richtung nato gesagt die nato führe in
der ukraine einen stellvertreterkrieg
durch diese eben jetzt auch diskutierten
waffenlieferungen wie schätzen sie das
ein also die nukleare nun hatten wir
bereits in den ersten tagen auch die
russischen nuklear streitkräfte sind
einen höheren bereitschaftsmodus gesetzt
worden aber das haben ja zuvor auch in
dem georg in krise und anderswo gesehen
dass das je bei jedem größeren konflikt
passiert das aber diese drohungen sind
aus meiner sicht nicht ernst zu nehmen
natürlich kann irgendwann die situation
kommen wo russland erkennt dass es
überhaupt keine kriegsziele mehr
erreicht ja und dann besteht tatsächlich
die gefahr wobei ich die gefahr des
einsatzes von chemischen waffen höher
einstuft als die gefahr von taktischen
nuklearwaffen weil taktische
nuklearwaffen und die diese nukleare
schwelle zu überschreiten ist etwas ganz
besonderes und damit sind sehr viele
eskalationen verbunden ich glaube nicht
dass russland ein interesse hat russland
hat aber ein interesse die natur durch
da rauszuhalten russland hat bereits
ganz am anfang schon diese nuklear
umgemünzt und hat sogar da zum ersten
mal hinein gebracht dass wir auch keine
sanktionen gegenüber russland wir
schließen dürften auch das können eine
nuklear waffen und einsatz sozusagen
auslösen also die reaktion mit der
drohung verbunden vielleicht auch eine
reaktion auf das verstärkte engagement
jetzt der nato eben durch diese
waffenlieferungen durch die sanktionen
die vielleicht doch auch ein stück weit
dann härter treffen als man sich das
gewünscht hat und vor allem auch
eigentlich ist es eine politisch
psychologische kriegführung sozusagen
aber auch an der stelle müssen wir punkt
machen gefragt um auch vielen dank für
den moment denn wir wollen noch mal
schauen auf die ja doch überraschende
meldung des tages nämlich zum treffen
der verteidigungsminister in ramstein
kam heraus dass der rüstungskonzern
krauss maffei wegmann nun doch gepard
flugabwehr